What's one interview question
you ask every prospective employee?
I'm fortunate that
a bunch of my founding team
is still with me,
and we were friends off the bat
so we can be very comfortable
with each other.
So, I'd say the first question
I ask is actually,
"Tell me your story."
It may seem pretty simple,
but really what I'm looking for
is creativity,
honesty,
and probably the most
important characteristic
that no one ever talks about
is sense of humor.
If you can't roll with
my existing team
and laugh at
the same jokes as us
and get it done at
the same pace as us,
then you can't
contribute to the team,
and that would be
horrible for you, you know?
You don't want to be
in an environment
where you don't really feel
like you're a part of the family.
So, I start from there.
What's your story?
Who are you?
Click any of these
fortune cookies to see
your questions and
follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return
to the intro video
and see what this series
is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.